[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number lambda
oopsilon point three seven seven one
also known as one oh nine uh one on well
that's the old numbering scheme it is
i'm trying out something new here that's
the new math
well it's not really so much math it's
like a
hybrid between you know public health
policy and the dewey decimal system it's
it's a mashup
a mashup that fails in every regard you
know pretty much pretty much well that
does seem timely
yeah just in time to get it under the
wire for 2021 yeah
so here we are um this is uh perhaps
this is going to be our last regularly
scheduled live stream of 2021 but we are
likely to have one more just not not on
christmas not next saturday and also not
on new year's actually that reminds me i
should tell them
this is our last opportunity to alert
you that winter is in fact coming
it is so soon so soon so soon in fact
we're going to end the show today with
uh
a few a few missives brief missives from
australia where uh winter is coming sure
but uh summer is really uh coming to be
in full swing just about now and what is
it feeling like there um from from the
the brains of one of our friends who
lives there
um
we are going to be talking today about a
little bit about obesity as we've talked
about before and uh its implications for
kovid
which we got to by thinking more about
children we were asked in our q a last
week about
someone on the school board
of his child's school
was putting together arguments
uh against mass mandates for school
children and you know he had he had this
sort of lack of efficacy in children and
low
lack of efficacy for masks for everyone
and uh low rates of covet and children
uh but what we had said was you know
it's just it's so bad it's so bad for
them
developmentally in terms of what it is
that they are and what it is they're
going to be and i thought i was thinking
more about that answer last week and
thought we'd go a little bit further
today so
we're going to tackle obesity about
children about uh something you have
termed ethical offense
and again uh a bit from australia and
first
logistics eh yeah let's do that okay
a yeah okay um logistics number a
logistics number a indeed um so we're
likely to do a live stream sometime
between christmas and new year's but um
there are actually three darker's
podcasts that you have recorded with
other guests
that are that will be dropped somewhere
between sometime between now and three
weeks from now they're all i have not
seen any of them but i've heard
tremendous amount about them and talked
with some of the guests and they they
look to be extraordinary mind-blowing
each i promise yeah yeah
uh so we aren't going to give anything
more away
about that but there will be this is not
this is not a dry spell for dark horse
uh we're just not going to be live
streaming on again christmas or new
year's
our book a hunter-gatherer's guide to
the 21st century uh
was uh we had signed copies available we
went up to the islands to the san juan
islands specifically to orcas island to
darvil's bookshop last week to sign
copies and we signed a lot of copies and
uh
all the copies they had and they had a
lot of copies and they're all sold out
unfortunately i have been having
travelers check flashbacks ever since
yeah
yeah um it's it's worse than um the
number of signatures you have to do when
you when you sign a phone you sign
get a mortgage right um it was it was it
was a lot of signatures we were grateful
to do it we're glad to do it um but
there aren't any more available at the
moment there won't be any more available
at least until after after christmas so
um please do continue to support
darval's it's a wonderful independent
bookstore uh but at the moment you can't
get signed copies of hunter gatherer's
guide from them they do have more books
they're just not signed they came in
after we left if you find yourself at
and you
need to pee
if you're male you will discover i think
actually probably works for females too
but the uh the the restroom has maybe
one of the most marvelous views of i
mean most restrooms have no view
whatsoever it's an independent bookstore
with one little tiny bathroom it's not
sex segregated
no no it's it's really a question yeah
if you're standing outside when you walk
in you do yeah i think your women don't
like
i don't know what it would be like crab
walk into the bathroom well the question
is i mean actually you're looking up at
mount constitution i guess if you're
seated so it's probably a very nice a
very nice view as well but i can assure
you that in the mail typical peeing
position the view is spectacular and
it's worth a trip to the restroom and
worth a trip to the bookstore yes that
that as well yes
um but i also wanted to mention um the
translation rights to hunter gatherers
guide have been sold and there's still
lots of offers coming in lots more that
will be sold but i just wanted to list
off the translation rights to our book
have already been sold
for i'm just going to say the countries
here lithuania poland spain romania
south korea thailand vietnam russia
france and china
and many more are in the works and we're
told that they can take a long time to
actually come to fruition although we
know the french publisher is hoping to
have its translate translation done and
available for people as of may of next
year so we're hoping that all of these
happen fast and that's that's exciting
and it's a little it's a little weird
because in most of those languages we
have zero ability to assess the
translation and none of them do we have
an excellent ability because we're just
neither of us is fluent in any other
language as much as we wish that weren't
true i'm actually hoping that for some
of the english-speaking countries that
have separate rights we will be
approached to do
the audiobook and we can try some really
over-the-top accents
yes
that would be excellent excellent
uh okay if
uh let's see oh well we we're for now
still on youtube and on odyssey the chat
is live on odyssey you can ask questions
for the q a that will follow this
episode at www.dark
please consider joining our patreons as
always uh this month the uh private q a
is not on the final but the penultimate
we sunday of the month which is say
tomorrow so if you join
my patreon before then you can join us
for a live
uh
patreon q a it's two hours starting at
11am tomorrow pacific time and we leave
it up afterwards so you can you can
always watch it later but we it's small
enough that we're able to actually
interact with the chat and sometimes our
friend fairfax shows up for that as well
and here he is being very lovey on
camera for those of you just listening
with oh
the products that are still available at
star
store.darkerspodcast.org include saddle
up the direwolves we ride tonight
digital brook burning the epic tabby
himself and uh various more there are a
number more in the works but none will
be available before
before the new year
consider going over to natural
selections
my sub stack where what we talked about
last week i made a list with a little
bit more information on those 12
important books and added added one to
the list
with our friend drew schneidler wrote
about gifting traditions two weeks ago
and for this upcoming tuesday we'll have
uh the complete rendering from our
friend in australia about what he's
seeing there so we're gonna finish off
today's episode by reading some from
that but on tuesday we'll post for for
public consumption you don't have to pay
are you going to do a follow-up on
re-gifting traditions
uh
you know the gifting traditions it's
interesting um the gifting gifts and
traditions that uh drew and i
wrote about
we we brought about frogs and spiders
and such too but um naturally
naturally um as as one does
some people do um
but the re-gifting traditions
specifically in the
kung did it and in iran uh which were
the two non-weird uh traditions that we
talked about specifically have
rules and and regs basically around
re-gifting and it is in fact uh for the
kind of formal gifting that is done as
opposed to that between intimates in at
least a few decades ago in iran it is
not only expected that you will re-gift
but
actually not only okay but expected even
when it's boxes for pastries so you just
have to do it fast enough that they
aren't stale by the time you re-gift
them but there's actually very little
expectation that you eat them um
yourself that there's there's a
tradition of just you know passing along
it's it's the it's the act of giving as
opposed to the gift itself
well i was kidding but that sounds
fascinating
yes yeah there's that was i learned as
to drew a lot about that from one
particularly uh long and interesting
paper that appear if memory serves was
written by a woman
who i don't remember which in which
order it happened she either came to be
living in iran and then became a
cultural anthropologist
and then also married into the culture
or it may have been the other direction
but either way she had both the you know
the personal intimate way in and also
the
the participant observers i trained as a
social scientist i believe right the
i've made every mistake in the book and
now i'm going to describe them to you
in hilarious detail exactly exactly okay
without further ado we have three
ads this week we are as we have said
repeatedly very grateful to our sponsors
they have been uh
they have really helped us know that we
can continue this as other sources of
funding have become more tenuous so we
have three this week and we will
continue to have uh three
most weeks for the foreseeable future uh
we have homedics four sigmatic and
public goods
so our first sponsor excuse me our first
sponsor this week is homemadex which
makes an air purifier that actually
lives up to expectations we've said a
lot about the health benefits of being
outside of course in the fresh air
scientists have figured out some but not
all of why being outside is so good for
you but sometimes you can't be outside
and sometimes indoor spaces aren't
amenable to being totally cleared out by
opening windows and if for instance
you've got pets as we do in your home
there's a good chance you've sometimes
got smells that you don't want
enter homedics total clean air purifier
it uses true hepa filtration and uvc
technology capturing 99.9 of the
bacteria virus mold and fungus that were
assessed in third-party testing as well
as pollen and smoke in our experience it
reduces all sorts of predators as well
as lingering cooking spells that are
wonderful at the time but maybe you'd
rather not wake up the next morning
still smelling yesterday's sausages and
pasta for instance this air purifier
cleans large rooms fast and is quite
inexpensive compared to similar items on
the market it's compact easy to carry
and not ugly it also has both a low
setting that is silent and three
different light settings one of which is
no lights on even when the filter is
running which is terrific so there's no
unavoided unavoidable blue lights on
this thing
so whether you're dealing with allergies
or just looking to keep your house
smelling fresh at times of year when you
can't throw open all the doors and
windows go to homedics.com darkhorse and
use promo code darkhorse you'll receive
a free replacement filter with the
purchase of your air purifier up to a 99
value make sure you add the replacement
filter to your cart or else the promo
code won't work that's a free
replacement filter when you go to
h-o-m-e-d-i-c-s
dot com slash darkhorse and use the
promo code darkhorse
our second sponsor for today is for
sigmatic which we have come to you with
very often uh you are frequent viewers
of darker so we'll be familiar with the
drill by now but uh here we go four
sigmatic is a wellness company known for
its delicious mushroom coffee as well as
protein powders that contain mushrooms
that's a little weird yep and delicious
also true
four sigmatics mushroom coffee contains
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms
four sigmatics ground mushroom coffee
with lion's mane adds a little something
some crispness some focus i find it's
delicious just like your favorite coffee
dark and nutty
and the protein powders added to a
smoothie or banana bread for instance
punch up the protein a little and again
give a little something and don't change
the taste
except for for instance the peanut
butter protein powder which added to a
smoothie with banana honey cacao nibs
peanut butter and milk and or dairy-free
alternative increases the peanut buttery
flavor which is a good thing
all four sigmatic products are organic
vegan and gluten-free and every batch is
third-party lab tested to ensure its
purity and safety and they have a 100
money back guarantee love every sip or
get your money back
so we have an exclusive offer with four
sigmatic on their best-selling mushroom
coffee for dark horse listeners get up
to 40 off free shipping on mushroom
coffee bundles to claim this deal go to
4sigmatic.com
darkhorse that's f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com slash darkhorse and fuel your
productivity and creativity with some
delicious mushroom coffee
all right third up is public goods our
final sponsor for today
public goods was also one of our very
first sponsors back in may of 2020 and
we are still as pleased with them now as
we were at the beginning public goods
can simplify your life as a one-stop
shop for everyday essentials their
ingredients are carefully sourced high
quality and affordable
public goods has ramen and mustard
deodorant and dental floss shampoo
coffee and a french press to make your
coffee in they've got grain free granola
and curry paste flatware and towels
there is so much at public goods to make
a meal including the materials to serve
it on public goods products have a great
design too the aesthetic is simple and
clean and there are no garish colors i
don't want the products that i use to
draw attention to themselves and public
goods products fit the bill
public goods cares about health and
sustainability their products are
largely free of harmful ingredients and
additives and the ingredients are
ethically sourced
they are also
they also plant one tree for every order
placed finally
their subscription service is efficient
and simple and easy to use public goods
members can buy all of their premium
essentials in one place it really is an
everything store
for dark horse listeners we have the
following offer receive 15 off your
first public goods order with no minimum
purchase they are so confident that you
will absolutely love their products and
come back again and again that they are
going to give you 15 to spend on your
first purchase go to publicgoods.com
darkhorse
use the code darkhorse at checkout or
use the code darkhorse at checkout that
is public goods p u b l i c g o o
s dot com forward slash dark horse to
receive 15 off your first order
all right that's our sponsors for the
week one more thing i just wanted to
follow up on from last week before we
get into the meat of the show is that
another question out of the discord i
think from last week that we answered in
our q a was effectively how do you
source and um
and assess the supplements because we
have we have said
that neither of us is a fan of
supplements we have never we've never
taken supplements before but in this era
we have come to understand a
how
how common vitamin d deficiency is and
also
how useful vitamin c zinc and some
ionophore like quercetin are in in
keeping healthy especially when there
are when it's when it's respiratory
virus season uh as winter seems to be
uh including not just covid but uh
things like other coronaviruses like
colds and flus other chronic rises like
colds and also the flu um not
i did invisible punctuation there
so a number of people wrote in because i
talked a little bit about what we had
done but um said that we didn't have a
great answer for figuring out how to
assess supplements and a number of
people wrote in suggesting
uh consumerlab.com
and i went and looked and
well in fact one of my patrons katie
said
i've used consumerlab.com for a number
of years they're not perfect but they do
some testing for things like lead and
whether the supplement actually has the
amount that they claim to have
the research they show the research both
good and bad for each supplement and the
form that it takes and this is something
i mentioned the molecular form that may
or may not be for instance bioavailable
and um and she says you have to
subscribe but they have a cost breakdown
for different brands and which is
cheapest uh so it sounds kind of like a
consumer reports but specifically for
for
supplements and other related things and
i went there i assessed it a little bit
i actually subscribed i assessed it some
more and i find that it is as good as
people are recommending so that's
consumerlab.com
which um
which seems to be if you can afford a
subscription or even just do it for one
month and
figure out everything you want to know
about where to source supplements uh
which supplements are the right
things to do so the idea is the lab
generally surveys supplements it's not
that you're sending them something to
check no they you do not send them
things they're not they're not an
in-house
um
they don't do it that way uh you look at
what they have already assessed yes
but it really is um it's quite
exhaustive
it's it's quite exhaustive and and quite
good okay
um so all of that out of the way
i wanted to i wanted to return
first to talking a little bit about the
comorbidity for covid and the general uh
um
sort of life comorbidity if you will and
i'm not sure that's that's how uh
doctors or clinicians or researchers
would say it but that is obesity we've
talked about this a lot before in fact i
uh found that we talked about it first
in our live stream number nine you mean
it's a comorbidity across many different
things not just covet is that what you
mean yeah i mean it's yeah i guess it's
a it's a it's a risk factor uh for early
death and other bad health outcomes in
general
and with regard to covid we were talking
about this as early as like i said april
21st 2020 in our in our ninth livestream
i went back and and looked assuming that
my my notes are complete
um i think we didn't talk about it
before then but we definitely talked
about it then
um so
i just before we talk about some of what
is going on with children i want to
review some of what we know about
obesity uh in uh with gerard
specifically to covid and in
live stream
number 69 on february 27th of this year
uh we
showed oh he's just showing me the wrong
paper here um actually
zach you can show this
table briefly and then maybe i'll just
pull it back um actually
apologies here's the paper it's a hern
at all 2021 called coronavirus disease
2019 hospitalizations attributable to
cardio metabolic conditions in the
united states a comparative risk
assessment analysis
if i may have my screen back here i
think i
made some
here we go just a couple of there we're
not going to go through the paper in
depth again we talked about this in
episode 69.
um they find and you may show my screen
here if you like zack in the abs from
the abstract as of november this is
published a while ago so this is not up
to date but we see nothing to suggest
that what they've found has been um
overturned
as of november 18 2020 an estimated 906
849 covered 19 hospitalizations occurred
in us adults
of these an estimated 20.5 percent with
95 percent
uncertain you know i'm not going to
focus on the numbers here an estimated
20.5 percent of covet 19
hospitalizations were attributable to
diabetes mellitus
30.2 to total obesity
uh with that is to say body mass index
over 30 kilograms per
meter square
meter squared um
i'm pausing because does
that make sense
um
square i'm going to have to go back and
look at how bmi is calculated it seems
to me that it's kilogram over
there is a relationship between height
yes but meters squared sounds like an
area right i don't think that's what
they mean i think the formula includes
the person's height squared somehow but
yeah okay um
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna skip
this i'm gonna
there's just a lot of numbers in there
that are not at the moment um making
immediate sense what are the clinical
implications of what they have found
having f found the top risks again were
obesity hypertension and diabetes they
say clinicians should educate their
patients who may be at risk and consider
promoting preventative lifestyle
measures such as improved dietary
quality and physical activity to improve
overall cardio metabolic health and
potentially minimize the risk for
chronic virus disease 2019 severity
sounds like a good idea does it not
um and finally there's one more thing
from this paper in the most recent cdc
analysis of available national data
among individuals diagnosed with cover
19
a 35 year old with diabetes hypertension
cardiovascular disease obesity or other
chronic conditions had a similar risk of
cova-19 related hospitalization as a 75
year old with none of these conditions
and a similar risk of copenhagen related
death as a 65 year old with none a
dramatic biologic aging effect of poor
metabolic health on risk of severity of
a viral infection such as coveting
so again a 35 year old with one of these
prime comorbidities um is in
worse shape um or as similar shape with
regard to covert risk as a 75 year old
with none of those risks it's amazing
which is an extraordinary finding so
thank you zach
given the steep aging curve of this
disease yeah because age is
it goes it goes from a trivial disease
for very young healthy people to a
spectacularly dangerous disease well
spectacularly dangerous a very dangerous
disease
to elderly in elderly people exactly and
the fact that um you know of course of
course it's not that simple but uh the
amount to which
to some degree especially if you are
currently healthy staying healthy is
relatively easy
and if you have one of these conditions
in so far as you can in as much as
possible taking control of your own
health and getting your weight down
getting your hypertension under control
to some degree
can actually affect outcomes across
across domains and so we have also
talked about however the fact that the
clinical suggestions here that health
officials and doctors advise patients to
you know to lose weight and to to
address the health conditions that they
can actually control as opposed to
as opposed to simply relying on external
sources of health which is what the the
single-minded uh public policy on
dealing with covid seems to be
um basically isn't happening now we did
talk in um
a couple live streams ago in 107 i guess
about some health
advice that's coming out of florida now
in which they're actually saying go
outside get active eat healthy you know
move your body and it sounds great but
it's literally the only one that i've
found i'm certainly not hearing anything
like this at the federal level
and what we have seen
is and i'm going to just revisit since
this is again from our ninth livestream
a piece that we saw in wired and then
one from the l.a times more recently uh
that
what is the mainstream media doing with
this kind of actual research results
around comorbidities and covet and how
you can reduce your risk well in
april 17 2020
wired
published a piece called cova19 does not
discriminate by body weight the claim
that those with higher bmis are at
special risk of dying from the
coronavirus is grossly overstated
and
here very quickly just zach show my
screen
to to demonstrate that this is this is
in fact what the article uh
what the article looks like
one of the things they said is obesity
appears to be one of the biggest risk
factors related to coven 19
hospitalizations and critical illness
newsweek claimed on tuesday yet this
rhetoric is based on flawed and limited
evidence which only exacerbates the
stigma that larger-bodied people already
face in society in our health care
system the stigma is what truly
jeopardizes their health not weight
itself wow in fact it's only more
important to consider in the midst of
this pandemic
the stigma is what jeopardizes their
health and the article ends with this
gem
instead of trumpeting the supposed risks
of high bmi and adding to the already
damaging impact of weight stigma
researchers need to be asking deeper
questions and public health officials
and journalists need to report on the
science in more nuanced and sensitive
ways
as of today december 18 2021 there is
neither a correction or attraction
anywhere associated with that article
from wired which is from april 2020.
when we already knew that obesity was
comorbidity and we still know that
follow the sensitive science
follow the sensitive people and their
feelings there you go yeah wow that's
really fascinating and i must say i do
think that uh you know
bmi is a proxy for something and it's
fun it's deeply flawed
but
you know all else being equal does bmi
correlate with
risk for covid it clearly does it
clearly does um and so the question is
okay you could add nuance to this right
for one thing bmi is such a crude
measure in its formulation
that you really don't know very much
about you know
whether someone is overweight or how
overweight they are based on the simple
measure because there are body shape
differences
and obviously you know somebody can have
an awful lot of uh you know muscle mass
there's a level at which that can become
a hazard in and of itself but basically
there's a lot of variation that isn't
captured in this one measure
but it's a you know it's a decent proxy
and it's in to the you know all of the
sorts of measures that we take
erase a certain amount of nuance in
order to discover a pattern and the
point is yes you can also study the
pieces of nuance and you get a
diminishing returns pattern where you
know bmi may explain the lion's share of
the pattern and then you can recover
other things from
from different factors but the idea that
a high bmi can reverse
the risk stratification for age
right in coba 19 that's incredible it's
a clear it's a clear pattern right and
the point is it doesn't mean that an
individual's bmi tells you anything
because the individual could be a
bodybuilder or whatever but um but
nonetheless the pattern is there and to
deny it on the basis
um that you know it
causes stigma which is the health
concern is obviously upside down and
backwards right and frankly most
individuals
know this you know if
if you're huffing and puffing after
climbing one set of stairs somewhat
slowly
you're probably not in very good health
i mean in fact i don't know why i'm
hedging with probably i don't i don't
know the situation in which if you're if
you're short of breath after climbing
one flight of stairs
i do not know the situation in which you
are in peak health
uh it could be that you just have
something temporary it could be that uh
you climb the stairs too soon after
having run five miles
and that you're not back at baseline but
uh you know we know this and yes there
are people who have you know
who way more than what the standard
suggests they should who are healthy of
course there are
but
that is not
there is so much evidence there is so
much evidence that obesity is a risk
factor across
many many health conditions and
specifically for coping well i want to
push back there because i don't know
what it's like to be 90. it's possible
that a healthy 90 year old might be
huffing and puffing after a single
flight of stairs i i just don't i don't
know um so i won't say you know it's
there's no case but yeah the point is
you know if you're
40 50 a single flight of stairs
shouldn't throw you like that and to the
extent that it does that's nature's way
of telling you you need to build more
capacity right um so
anyway it's a minor pushback but yeah no
i i i hear that um
let me
there's just another there there are a
lot of these but there's another amazing
piece on obesity and covert from the la
times which was published this year not
that recently may 9th 2021
it's called fat shaming bmi and
alienation covet 19 brought new stigma
to large sorry larger sized people no
large sized people
so you can i'm going to read just the
first short six paragraphs of this
and i i do not know how to pronounce the
names here uh crystal bogon cried after
the after the needle went into her arm
not because her first dose of the
modernity vaccine hurt but because
finally being fat actually paid off
the 53 year old was inoculated in the
parking lot of kaiser permanente in san
jose on a rainy friday in march four
days after eligibility in california was
broadened to include people with
underlying conditions among them a body
mass index of 40 or more 233 pounds for
an adult who is five feet four inches
tall
bogan's medical record at kaiser shows
she is morbidly obese as an activist she
prefers the word fat
her experience with medical providers
has been one incident of size stigma
after another she said like the time she
went in with a scratched cornea and was
told to lose weight
she fears being hospitalized with covet
19 and unable to advocate for herself
for that reason i decide you know what
i'm not going to feel guilty about being
vaccinated i'm going to do what she said
and i'm not going to apologize for it
i've been in fear the whole flip in time
staying home avoiding everybody i
couldn't do my job i'm an electrologist
i removed facial hair i couldn't come to
work i couldn't make money
that however is changing thanks to a
viola vaccine a very sharp needle and a
policy switch that allowed women and men
like bogan a chance to be inoculated
before the general public in california
about a month early
it's not every day that we get something
for free because we're fat said bogon
who launched a youtube channel called
fat product review
we'll stop there for now um
go for it well i just i just wanted to
say a couple things i mean this story is
layer upon layer of
betrayal yes right the idea that we are
going to at this stage
now
champion
obesity obesity
and portray this as the point at which
it pays off is obviously absurd but
let's just say civilization has failed
this person right the epidemic of
obesity is not about people not caring
people don't choose to be obese right
they can't control something and the
thing that they can't control is
obviously in the realm of what we talk
about in our book hypernovelty right
this is not a genetic defect this is
something about our ancient selves
encountering a modern world in which
there are there is a factor or there are
a number of factors that combine to
cause that system to get out of whack
and
we ought to be if you know i mean this
is
uh increasingly um glaring but we have
public health officials that are
apparently willing to turn civilization
absolutely upside down and to withdraw
all sorts of fundamental rights in order
to advance a one-size-fits-all policy
that is clearly not based in science
and yet
there is no interest whatsoever they're
obsessed with our health as long as the
topic is this narrow focus and the
solution in question is the only one
that they allow us to discuss right
they're obsessed with our health in that
case but there and provides no agency
for us no agency in fact the point is
actually there are things you can do to
protect yourself from covet and they're
specifically not advising them right
they're not advising us to take vitamin
d they're not advising people hey this
would be a great moment in fact you know
what there is at the moment with respect
to getting your weight under control
extra reason to motivate right there's a
disease out there and it will afflict
you worse so hey if you needed a little
extra push in that direction here it is
are they saying that no they're saying
you know embrace your high bmi right
that makes no sense and some people are
saying talking about high bmi being a
risk factor is itself a form of fat
shaming and that it's not the high bmi
it's the stigma that's making people
sick and
no no it's it's not and again as you say
that's not to say that there isn't
stigma and that's not to say that you
know especially especially for people
um who became
fat as children there are there are in
many cases developmental processes which
cannot be undone such that people will
be you know chronically struggling to
get their weight under control and it
really is not um easy for them to the
extent that it's easy for anyone who
gains 10 or 20 pounds to lose it it's
not the same problem it is not the same
problem this isn't a simple thing just
like bmi is a flawed and overly
simplistic rubric it's not you know
calories in calories spent it's not that
simple an equation that actually doesn't
work it depends on you know what it is
that you're eating under what conditions
what else you're doing with your life
and also what your history looks like
and you cannot change that what's done
is done
right and of course you know we are
creating the problem you know one of the
the puzzles that we run into with all
sorts of things whether it's
uh the
need for glasses the need for
orthodontia or uh you know a lifelong
battle with with obesity all of these
things are the result of some influence
right an influence that even if we can't
help people who are already afflicted we
can prevent it from afflicting anybody
else right if you figure out why it is
that kids suddenly need orthodontia and
you stop doing that thing to them then
you don't need any more orthodontia for
younger people and you just have to deal
with the people who already have the
issue and the point is
were these people at all interested in
our health they would be focused on
years of life that people are being
robbed of by conditions they would be
focused on quality of life being lost
and there would be some sort of rational
formula that says we should prioritize
this thing because it is robbing people
of the most quality or uh years of life
and we are obviously not doing that you
know in fact even the way we calculate
the harm of covet is absurd right
because the point is that
damage done to young people is vastly
more important than damage down to the
very old just by virtue of the number of
years of theirs that you compromise and
so the idea that you know vaccines good
is nonsense right because the point is
who you're giving them to and how much
they stand to benefit versus lose it's
not the same parameter and yet we
pretend that it is so that we can get
one number and
um at some level i think we have to call
their bluff they're obviously not
interested in our health i don't know
why they are interested in what they're
interested in it could be that it's
money it could be that it's something
else but for god's sake it's clear that
their obsession their um
the appearance that they are obsessed
with our well-being relative to covid is
not uh real because if it was they'd be
obsessed with our health on other topics
too and they clearly aren't they clearly
are not
um
one more one more quote from this los
angeles times article from may of this
year
in other words
in other words said reagan chastain who
is the author of fat the owner's manual
and has written widely on weight bias
and medical research quote if fat bodies
experience something more than thin
bodies fat bodies are to blame rather
than the unequal treatment fat people
receive due to weight stigma
so
she
i actually don't know
that person reagan chastain
is saying
this is a mistake
that um pointing out that um
being fat is correlated with outcomes is
a mistake and that is again due to
stigma so
it just it just goes
it just goes on and on and on
but all of that is in service of talking
about children because as it turns out
maybe even more so in children although
it is difficult to parse the data that
we are being shown because we are not
generally being shown all of it as
always the data are duped all the way
down some level um even more so for
children to the extent that children
suffer from covid and the vast vast vast
majority of them do not
to the extent that they do
they almost always have a comorbidity
and obesity is
is one of the major ones for children as
well so let me
um
yeah children don't die of coven and
they don't get sick from cobin here is
um
the cdc's
data uh i i'm trying here to go to
the government
the government's information the cdc the
fda exactly the people he would expect
if they are not giving us everything
they are going to air in the direction
that serves their narrative yes as
opposed to even by their own numbers
even by their own numbers
what we have here is um
is deaths this is through uh
12 15 20 21 so it's updated regularly
starting with january 1st 2020 each line
is
um
it's split by sex
and age
total deaths in that age group for this
period of time and deaths attributed to
covid i will say you know they say covet
19 deaths i'm going to say death's
attributed to covet because increasingly
that's one of the ways that we
are sure that the data are being juked
for instance and it's one of the places
that the literal bodies are figuratively
buried is by
categorizing things and it's clear you
and i've been through this multiple
times it is clear that there is a
narrative that starts this right covet
is to be maximally terrifying and the
one-size-fits-all vaccine policy is to
be maximally beneficial and things are
moved by category in order to reflect
that narrative even though it's clearly
not a straightforward conclusion exactly
so for those just listening i'm going to
i'm going to scroll down i'm going to
try to no doesn't want me to um
and uh
and show
that as you get to you know
as you go up in age again this is just
this is just girls coming into women uh
the number of deaths in the age group
increase because deaths increase um you
know you have a lot of deaths in the
first year of life because uh we are we
are born fragile and we become
anti-fragile uh with age if we are
allowed to be uh but we are born very
fragile and fragile and easy to misplace
we never did that i swear to god
um that's what screaming's about yes
that is what's screaming that's how it
starts out yeah um so the you know the
overall deaths in the group
unfortunately you can't well actually um
here sorry uh i can't nope don't show
that zack sorry here we go um
yeah you can show this
uh
and oh actually you can't really so
you're seeing i didn't have time to do
all the right stuff here um
this is this is just the same data in a
spreadsheet uh where you can see that i
didn't i didn't make the formatting nice
uh the number of deaths increases as you
go up and the number of coba deaths
increases
up until um
you know the number of deaths in women
over 85 was is well over a million uh
total deaths and the number of
deaths attributed to covid are over a
hundred thousand
consistent with the kinds of numbers
we've seen and now we start over this is
this is now males and again it starts
out super low and it just climbs and
climbs and climbs and if we look at just
the 18 and under mortality data
we have a total number of deaths
attributed to covet in
um people under 18 in the u.s is 655
across the entire pandemic 655 deaths
in the u.s for people under 18. and if
you take out that first year
where you're super fragile and even more
so who knows to what extent those um
dead with covet was actually dead of
covid if you take those out you're less
than 500 you're at 492 total kova deaths
according to the cdc's numbers
uh in the u.s across the entire pandemic
so what does that tell us um that tells
us again um that children aren't dying
of coven
and
that furthermore we got to be careful i
mean obviously 500 is
a lot of kids it's a tiny number it's a
tiny number compared to all of the kids
who have died and
uh and the fact is that compared to
every older age group
is a tiny number
um so yes it's not binary it's not zero
yep but it's actually closer than any
other
demographic description of a disease
progression that i as i've seen well i
would also leave open the possibility
that it is zero given the
noise but i just want to say 500 if
that's the real number right it's not
zero it's a large number of kids in
absolute terms but compared to other
causes of death it is very tiny and i
think i know where you're headed here
you were not headed somewhere further
i'm going somewhere further but i didn't
think you were done with your sentence
sorry
it was one of those sentences that just
ended abruptly in the middle there was a
sentence cliff and
okay um
well
man nothing is working quite so one of
the places i wanted to go from here is
to show this fda document that came out
in october
october 26 2021
called vaccines and related biological
products advisory committee meeting this
was a document prepared again by the fda
in service of allowing mrna coded
vaccines in five to 11 year olds so
again the point of this document is to
provide evidence that what we need are
euas four five to eleven for the
vaccines to be allowed in five to eleven
year olds which of course as we know
were granted so again just like with the
cdc data
i'm going to the source that i would
expect to have
um
to be to be biased towards the narrative
not away from the narrative and yet and
yet even here
we find things that don't quite fit uh
with the narrative here's here's their
page four and i will this is a pdf that
i'm showing but i'll i'll link
i'll post the link in the show notes um
this is covered weekly cases
in across all age groups uh
and it looks it looks scary you know
look at those peaks the peaks for all
age groups you have the light blue line
um is lowest that's zero to four year
olds and it basically gets the peaks get
higher the older the age groups are
but the peaks are mirroring one another
to some degree okay
that seems like
evidence that you might want to be
thinking about but then you go to page
11 in this document
and what this is doing for those just
listening is tracking
flu deaths or no flu hospitalizations
and covet hospitalizations uh flew from
2017 um yearly from the 2017-2018 year
flu season 2018 2019 2019 20 20 20 21
and then covered from the beginning or
actually from october 2020 uh through
september 2021 so a comparable amount of
time they've
controlled for the amount of time
ish
and what we find here is that you know
yes mitigation uh measures have been in
place and so you would expect hopefully
covet was spreading less than it might
have been and the flu was spreading less
than it might have been um but check out
that flu cases are effectively zero
there are nine pediatric influenza
hospitalizations reported between in the
2020 to 2021
flu season nine
compared to
um in other years
um
we don't actually have the absolute
numbers we just have rates per 100 000
of the population the rates are so low
from last year that it's effectively
zero as you can see on this on this and
they of course have not given us the
actual ability to compare apples to
apples here
and
the covid uh
hospitalizations are lower
than pediatric hospitalizations from flu
in previous years again there were
mitigation measures in in place
um and
but you know but
still
what happened was flu dropped to nothing
so none of none of those
hospitalizations happened
and we know that at least in some cases
some of the tests that were supposedly
testing for covid were impossible to
discriminate between whether or not they
were testing for covert or flu
so how many of these covet cases are
actually flu cases we don't we don't
necessarily know we don't know i mean
and i will say the
flu number dropping to zero could be
a lot of different things it could have
a lot of different contributors and we
need to point out that one possibility
is
data shenanigans that uh basically if it
coughs it has covid kind of a thing
[Music]
more likely i would say is the strong
possibility that flu has become very
well adapted to our modern way of life
and we thoroughly disrupted our modern
way of life and interrupted its ability
to transmit so flu had a rotten year
because we just simply weren't behaving
normally poor flu yeah poor flu but um
but anyway the the overarching point is
from the perspective of
addressing
the hazard to children that hazard has
to be scaled relative to flu in an
average year and the question is
are these vaccines
something that one should
offer to children should mandate for
children encourage for children in light
of the scale of the hazard
and
um
the problem is that you know they've
gotten in the way of every piece of the
analysis that rational independent
people without a dog in the fight would
have to go through in order to figure
out what the comparison is but at the
very least even if we knew nothing
of actual harm coming to children from
these vaccines which is not the state
we're in but even if that was the state
you would have to rate the risk that
there was something that would happen to
these children if vaccinated later in
life as too large to contemplate in
light of the very small risk that comes
from covet itself even given the the way
that numbers are calculated to inflate
that hazard
i
absolutely agree
and
two more slides from this uh document
that the fda produced
here we have children aged 5 to 11 years
hospitalized with covert 19.
this is march 2020 through august 2021
and what we don't see here
is um this is outcomes in children
versus comorbidities that's underlying
medical conditions um but what we don't
see is a number of
you know how many kids who ended up
hospitalized with covid um had any
co-morbidities that's the number i want
to see and i don't see it here but what
we do see is how many kids who are
hospitalized had greater than one oh no
that's equal to or greater than one
underlying conditions
um that's 68
so
more than two-thirds
of the kids who were hospitalized with
covet have
um one or more underlying conditions and
their underlying conditions frankly uh
include chronic lung disease obesity
cardiovascular disease
and you know things like feeding tube
dependence
and chronic metabolic disease but these
don't include all of the co-orbitals
that we know exist for covid
and also of course none of this includes
one of the factors that we have now come
to understand from our own research and
from conversations we've had um that
vitamin d deficiency is likely to be you
know if you add that in here i'll bet
that number 68
of kids hospitalized with cobit have at
least one underlying condition if you
count vitamin d deficiencies underlying
condition i'll bet that number goes
pretty close to one right and
if you were i mean we don't know it's
possible that the extremely compelling
vitamin d data does not include kids
because in all likelihood that work was
done on adults and so that and kids are
better able to synthesize vitamin d
right um so we have to leave open the
formal possibility that that the the
pattern the small amount of coveted in
or the small amount of cove coveted
disease that is worth talking about is
not heavily impacted by d and kids
there's no reason to think that the
assumption should be in the other
direction that kids more or less mirror
the adult pattern but we have to leave
open the possibility
but nonetheless
from the point of view of would you
rather gamble on giving a young person
with many more decades of life in front
of them and much more development to go
through a brand new technology vaccine
that oh by the way doesn't prevent
contracting the disease and doesn't
prevent transmitting the disease and
doesn't seem to reduce viral load but is
really great other than that right would
you and you may well become dependent on
more on more of it right so the number
of boosters in a lifetime you might have
to get is uh likely to be higher would
you rather go that route with all of the
uncertainties involved in all of that
or would you rather try vitamin d and
see whether the very minor problem that
kids seem to have with covid can be
largely addressed because they have a
cryptic vitamin d deficiency like
everybody else yes like everybody else
living in the temperate zones and i mean
of course we should say as we you know
this is a point that we were hammering
early on in in our dark horse live
streams
uh that we don't know the long-term
effects of coven
uh we don't know the degree to which
children who have long haul covered uh
will in fact you know may have shortened
life may have you know worse outcomes
from long covet because it has the
potential to last for longer because
they have longer lifespan ahead of them
etc we haven't we have no information on
this just as we don't on on anyone
because this thing has been around for a
long time at this point but it's still
in only two years right
um but but that said all of the
information that we do have suggests
that you know yes obesity is a risk
factor across all age groups and
children are at lowest risk for bad
outcomes from the disease
and they are
at
the same or in fact higher risk for bad
outcomes adverse events from the
vaccines especially boys as we've
outlined in other places on on the show
and so you know what
why is it
um that we are being asked to
enable a one-size-fits-all policy it's
not because
we're too dumb to track it
that may be part of the story and you
hear that from people people are too
stupid to to keep track and so you just
need to give them one solution and
that's what they'll do
uh you know we all get into that
headspace sometimes my god i don't want
to make another decision i just want to
have brand loyalty decision loyalty
something i want to just vote blue i
want to buy that kind of toothpaste i
want to go to that restaurant in order
that thing i just want to not think
about you know i've got i've got choice
fatigue
that is gaming the fatigue that we all
experience rather than actually
a an organic situation people do not
want to be handed single answers that
don't actually fit all solutions and are
being told that they fit all solutions
especially at the point that
they come to realize they've been lied
to and those lies have effects they have
effects on individual health and
societal health on economic health on
all the healths
yeah
it's uh
it doesn't make any sense that this is
about we can't handle the complexity for
one thing um
much of the vaccine hesitancy surrounds
a lot of us having seen the complexity
and
saying actually there's uh
too much uncertainty here to contemplate
this and the you know the longer that we
wait and the more we learn the more
frightening the picture that emerges
from what is apparently already known
becomes so i would point out in in
thinking about this question you're
comparing it against a lot of unknowns
with respect to how much hazard there is
to kids in these brand new novel
vaccines that would be true if there had
been no observation of harm whatsoever
but we are not in that circumstance in
fact
even in pfizer's trial on kids
which was tiny it was like 1200 kids
there was an absolutely serious adverse
event with permanent effects the maddie
degary case i think that's how you
pronounce your name
maybe digore but
in any case
this was a girl really a hero of the
pandemic somebody who volunteered to
test the vaccines because she wanted to
contribute to the solution to covid
she now has a feeding tube is
permanently in a wheelchair and the
reaction of pfizer was to unblind very
quickly and
basically she was uh
she was
written down in the report as if she had
had stomach upset this is a person who
is now on a feeding tube right this is a
person who is permanently injured in a
you know a group of about 1200 kids
that's not an insignificant number you
know in 1200 kids even a very high rate
of very serious reactions could have
been missed but in this case there
actually is a person she has a name and
she has a life ahead of her and you know
pfizer is effectively pretending that
she doesn't exist or is faking or
something like that and it's
preposterous and the fact is parents
have a right to know this and they have
a right to say no to these things yeah
and i feel like that's um
that should be the easy argument to be
having and of course we're not being
allowed to have it
um but maybe
what got me thinking specifically about
children and the way that we are frankly
destroying children's futures right now
was not even about the vaccines i'm
showing you data that was prepared in
service of getting the eua for vaccines
in 5 to 11 year olds
but
but i got thinking about it because of
how schools look and i guess schools
don't look this way all over the place
but certainly where we are and where a
number of places are there's still
uh mandatory masking in schools and and
other measures in place and um
actually let me just show this one last
screen here zach this is again from the
fda document this is page 14 of this fda
document which just shows the data from
the previous page in a different
graphical form underlying conditions as
risk factors in hospitalized children 5
to 11 years again march 2020 through
august 2021
in which obesity and chronic metabolic
disease um
show very and you know and things like
feeding tube dependence again
um
show up as strong risk factors for bad
outcomes from kovid
and you know i wonder if wired or the
l.a times would say that the fda is fat
shaming here this this is th
these are data
from the very organizations that refuse
to actually advise people that they need
to take control of their own health and
do have a single solution for everyone
that actually should not be the single
solution for people and even their data
show that obesity is a major risk factor
for children
you know and again across domains it's
not just covet it's not like oh well for
covet sure being fat may may be a
problem for you uh but no across domains
and again
because developmentally you set so many
things in motion that you then may not
be able to change later on the healthier
you are as a child the more likely you
are to be able to maintain and if you
lose it sometimes regain your health as
an adult
so
we wanted to actually show um
you know we
i've just been thinking about even even
now we're still we're in oregon with the
indoor mask mandates still and
i'm not you know i don't i don't like
consumption as an activity but uh i do
go into the stores sometimes and
uh and enjoy
enjoyed touching which we couldn't do
for a long time including produce but um
in a retail store you've been fondling
the produce well
always before right um but you know
ceramics in particular as a ceramicist
in a in a past life i i want to feel the
heft of it i want to feel how
how it feels in my hand i want to turn
it over and look at how it's been
trimmed and you know what the signature
looks like and all of this and um and
and look at the glaze inside and out and
um and i also want to smell things there
are a number of things that you can buy
that you they're actually about smelling
them and you can't smell through masks
very well you are going to love meta it
is very much like sorry that was a
terrible terrible joke yeah i'm really
not um going to love meta but you know
if that's if that's my experience
and i'm a middle-aged woman
who has long since come to understand my
embodied nature in the world
children are just coming to recognize
coming into in a knowledge of who they
are as embodied beings as as
intellectual beings as mental beings as
psychological beings
and they are learning how to use their
eyes and their noses and their fingers
and
to make eye contact with one another
which okay fine you can still do that
with a mask how to smile at one another
how to give
indications of mood
of agreement of tolerance of
disagreement of
intolerance with facial expressions
with with hugs
with refusals to hug with turning away
with all of these things that frankly
mask mandates and
keeping children from getting close to
one another
is
is going to have such remarkable
downstream effects and it's probably not
going to be traceable to to those things
but we are
even more than we were doing before with
our helicopter and snowplow parenting
and the pharmaceutical drugs that were
being handed to kids in the form of
speed and anti-anxiety meds and ssris
and the screens and you know having
destroyed the economy such they would
have a hard time ever imagining a future
in which they could own a house
all of that has been terrible and we've
written and spoken about that
extensively but this thing that we're
doing now to kids
in the schools
it's worse
and it's going to be very hard to undo
and i wanted to just show this video of
jen posaki
our
our
press secretary responding to a question
um about this from a reporter so zach
that is the video that we sent to you if
you could
okay
all right
one more question on school's uh
obviously the white house wants schools
to be open but encouraging schools open
yeah many schools are fully open but
inside schools they're often uh you know
very strict rules uh for example
sometimes students are required to eat
outside or eat distance from each other
not talk to each other while they're
eating does the white house want to see
those rules lifted as well to get back
to a more normal school experience well
schools are taking steps especially
since we've only recently approved
through the cdc and fda vaccines for
five to 11 year olds they're not
approved for kids younger than that to
keep their kids safe and keep students
safe i will tell you i have a
three-year-old who goes to school sits
outside for snacks and lunch wears a
mask inside and it's no big deal to him
i'm not saying that's the case for
everybody but these are steps that
schools are taking to keep kids safe and
i think the vast majority of parents
appreciate that obviously we want to get
to a point where we're turning to a
version of normalcy for everybody right
where you're not sending your kids
backpack with seven extra masks right
where you're not adding two hats so that
they're warm outside for a snack there's
no question that's the case but we also
think the most important thing should be
safety the safety of kids keeping kids
in school which the president is very
focused on and some of these steps
creative steps that schools have taken
have enabled that to be possible
yeah that's uh
incredible
to me there's so many
things in her statement
um
that
reveal the degree to which this is a
charade i mean for one thing she
specifically says in there
that this is you know this is well yes
all of these things are important but
it's about
keeping kids safe that's got to be our
top priority and
the more you think about that claim the
emptier it is yeah i mean in fact given
everything we know and you know as you
mentioned uh some minutes ago
the one caveat here the one asterisk is
that we can't say
with certainty that kids who have a very
very mild case of covid which is what
kids who are healthy are likely to have
if they get coveted at all
that those kids won't have some sort of
negative health consequence later in
life as a result of them having had
covet seems pretty unlikely it does but
possible but nonetheless cases in adults
don't seem to lead to long cobit for
instance therefore cases in kids tending
to be asymptomatic are less likely to
seem in keeping unlikely to lead to long
covet but it's not impossible that it
would manifest in a different way not
impossible we have to leave the door
open to that possibility but we can
basically say the presumption ought to
be no that they have mild cases they get
better they seem to end up with durable
immunity from it and therefore even the
idea that this is about keeping kids
safe
is preposterous and you know
think about it this way what we make the
argument we make in our book yeah is
that um the purpose of childhood is to
create durable high-capacity adults who
are dynamic and capable of navigating
risk and all of these things we're
talking about the immune system of such
a creature right it's in school and you
are keeping it safe from a disease today
that if it got the disease it would be
safe for the rest of its life in all
likelihood and instead of allowing it to
become safe for the rest of its life at
very low risk of any health consequence
you are going to stave off six months at
a time you're going to stave off this
disease
and and
so that later on in life when they are
more vulnerable that they are going to
have an encounter with it risking taking
out the young person's immune system
whether at least with regard to this
disease entirely right that makes no
sense and the mask thing is just so
unimaginative with respect to i mean
just the very fact as we talked about i
think last week the
highly unusual fact of human facial
musculature having
gotten all of this control specifically
for the purpose of exchanging
information about state of mind and
and
the point is you're going to interrupt
that
and you're going to say well
we don't think it's serious enough that
covet is more serious and that we're not
going to worry about the fact that we're
taking years of these kids lives and
we're going to block off this much of
their face
and you know
we were objecting early on to the
frankly largely coming from the right
statements that ah it's just the flu
it's
yeah it's less bad than the flu well in
children it appears to be less bad than
the flu yeah always has been
by a lot
and
keeping kids safe okay so we're gonna
pick one thing
one thing which makes kids unsafe one
thing
and
maximize that
like it's it's like these people have
never heard of trade-offs or diminishing
returns curves or you know anything
mature and wise about how it is that you
navigate a world in which actually it's
not just one variable
there's not just one variable if covitt
was literally the only risk to anyone
and there were no costs to these
mitigation measures then maybe
it's not the only risk and there are
known costs and you've got to know that
there are a lot of unknown costs too and
we are doing incredible damage and you
know also one of the other things that
she says in there is you know a her
three-year-old is in school which is a
bizarre claim but okay
but uh with three-year-olds in school
wears a mask snacks outside whatever um
he doesn't i think what she says is he
doesn't mind yeah
and this is consistent with the trans
activists also the trans rights
activists the tras
they would have us believe that
everything that a child conveys be it
actually stated in the case of trans
rights activists or um not stated in the
case of my kid doesn't mind
is the truth about that child and what
they currently believe to be true is
somehow magically turning into reality
as well now we don't believe it when the
kid claims he's a dinosaur um but when
he claims he's a girl we do believe it
and when a kid
tries to be a big boy
and doesn't
complain to his mom
who's the damn press secretary that
actually
he'd like to be able to hug his friends
and
maybe he doesn't even know
he probably doesn't know what he's
missing
right he's three and he's he's three he
doesn't know about seeing people's faces
on
you know without these things i've had i
had three different interactions with
children this week children i don't know
um
in stores
little children who were not masked
thankfully sometimes even the babies are
masked but these little children weren't
masts in or in oregon
everyone else is masked in stores
um but i was able to play these sorts of
like peek-a-boo games with these kids
and in their cases the moms
were fine with it sometimes they get
freaked out if a stranger wants to play
such a game with their with their kid
these kids were so
ecstatic
they seemed more ecstatic than usual to
just have some interaction in which
there was pleasure on the part of
another ape on the other side of the
interaction and i so wanted to just take
off my mask and let them see my face
but i didn't
and i thought again
what are we doing
how will we
ever end up knowing what all we have
brought
with with all of this
and
frankly who will be held accountable
yeah uh actually a mutual friend of ours
contacted me for advice this week um and
the question was literally
should i move
i'm concerned about yes
masks on my very young children and the
developmental effects this is somebody
who's actually considering upending
moving away from their family moving to
some state where this is a place that i
think the family has lived it's he's not
a first generation person there right
this is some this is a place where
somebody has roots and the idea is those
roots are up against the
normal developmental inputs that will
allow a person to become a full human
being and you know it was very difficult
to say well the masks suck but you know
it's not that bad because maybe it is
maybe it is that bad maybe it is that
bad and that actually isn't
um
let me read a little bit from this
excellent piece that came out this week
you may share my screen zack this is
from an outlet called front porch
republic which i did not know before
and the piece is by someone named teddy
macker called facts to faces on the
masking of children at school
so i'm just going to read from my pdf of
it
please know that were you to say to me
but teddy you're callous and out of
touch for carrying on like this my
father died of coven
i would bow and fall silent
but i also bow and fall silent when i
see the boy walking through the park
before school with his mask on
this child like so many other children
is haunted by a fear that's most likely
a phantom
as you may know of the 74 million people
in our country under 18 about 500 have
died of covet
of those 500 it seems some many had
underlying health conditions and if you
glazed over reading those last two
sentences we are all so numbers hungry
and yet numbers numb
please consider reading them again
in the interest of seeing life steadily
and seeing life whole these numbers
should be known
so wouldn't it be more sensible for that
boy to fear riding in the car on the
freeway with his texting prone sitter
or visiting the pool with friends
indeed it's easy to think like many do
that the masking of children is a
symptom of a large unwieldy and blind
momentum pretending a host of dystopian
changes and that we've collectively gone
nuts
i'm skipping a section here and it's
easy to think that we adults have
welched on a primary charge to teach the
children that the world even with the
fret and strife that accompany being
human is good beautiful and worthy of
our trust
social thinker and educational
philosopher rudolph steiner wrote quote
from the first to the seventh year
gesture predominates in the life of the
young child but gesture in the widest
sense of the word gesture that the child
lives in imitation
what kind of gesture one can only wonder
do they imitate now
one more section one wants to shout what
about the crappy pesticide-laced food so
many kids eat what about the plague that
is their physical inactivity what about
the gadgets driving us kids and adults
alike to suicidal soil soul ruin us
despair what about the public health
epidemic that is the internet who isn't
dying by inches because of the internet
what about the other challenges we face
that have been nudged aside and
forgotten and are actually greater than
copen19
and what about the challenge underlying
all these challenges a crisis of meaning
of spirit of a sacred hoop to borrow
from black elk that is broken and
scattered
this is an extraordinary piece and i
recommend everyone reading all of it but
he's exactly right we have replaced
all of our concerns with a single one
and we are being told to hate the people
who are on a different side of a single
line
as opposed to recognizing that we likely
agree completely with nobody else on the
planet and we likely disagree completely
with nobody else on the planet and that
those of us who see what is happening to
children and to and to democracy right
now
sometimes we feel like we're yelling
into a void
but we also know you and i know
and we hear from other people who are
speaking publicly that the amount
of voices that we hear in return
saying thank you keep it up what do i do
how do we get out of this
we don't have all of the answers by a
lot
but you have to know that you're not
alone that there are a lot of us out
here
yeah i've noticed uh i'm sure you have
too a theme has begun to emerge in the
many pieces of correspondence that we
get and it's interesting it's not the
first time this has happened to us where
a theme from you know
dozens hundreds of people who aren't in
contact with each other emerges
presumably because it's
separately evolving and bubbling up in
all of these different quadrants but the
theme is
thank you you are keeping me sane and i
increasingly i mean a i know as you know
exactly what they're talking about
because it is like um
i'm struggling for an analogy that is
not ant lions and what happens to an ant
that has gone over the edge of an ant
lion
you may have to describe airlines uh
antlions are the larva of an insect that
uh it sits at the bottom of a
hole that it is excavated and these
sides of the hole are steep and if you
step over the edge you slide further and
further in the more you struggle to get
out the more you kick the sand loose and
fall into the mouth of the antlion you
being an ant not a person red lions do
not come in a size such that a person
could fall into an antlion funnel trap
and die as far as we know i never have
seen it happen or described but of
course the people who would have been
able to describe it are presumably gone
into the mob right you the ant
find yourself struggling and making
reverse progress but um in any case
yes the antlion analogy is the struggle
to remain sane as effectively a thousand
different messages that induce you
towards insane conclusions come at you
from every angle they start coming out
of the mouths of your friends right and
the point is staying sane at this moment
is not a simple job
i do think you and i have been pointing
out in
ways big and small that the key to it is
finding other people you can trust and
trusting them right that's the thing
and so anyway apparently a lot of people
are getting
uh something necessary and vital from us
just by simply hearing a conversation
that it may be a lot of things but at
least it's not crazy
um so yeah and when and when we're wrong
we say it and when we disagree with one
another we say it and um that's how it's
supposed to work yeah we're trying to
make sense and when one of us says
something isn't quite right the other
one pushes back and you know the walls
don't collapse and
anyway it's kind of what sanity sounds
like i guess but um
in any case um that's that's a really
interesting and important theme to
suddenly be bubbling up in people's
minds and i believe it is uh an
important indicator of something
but i did want to say
i'm struggling between
two instincts on the mask thing i
increasingly think the mask thing is
diabolical especially as we inflicted on
children and pretend that it's going to
be low cost and that the reason that
we're doing it is about keeping them
safe from something that would actually
render them
perfectly safe indefinitely if they got
it
but
the
other thing is
there's some i think i must have picked
it up from fiction somewhere but there's
some sort of an obligation
to
respect a highly capable enemy
right to note what the enemy has done
right and you can imagine being some
kind of warrior on a battlefield and you
know
somebody out foxes you and you both
suffer from it but also
can appreciate the elegance of what
they've done
the mask thing is diabolical genius
it is absolutely diabolical genius
because of two things one
the symbolic nature of it
right the fact that they have gotten us
to remind each other
of just how dangerous everybody is if
you don't let your guard your literal
guard down right or if you do let your
literal guard down
that is a beautiful metaphor right
everybody else they're your enemy
they're a hazard to you right and the
point is unless you're sitting next to
them in a cafe
well that's the thing as you and i have
begun to joke about the coveted layer
the coveted layer exists up with the
wait staff right because they're
standing and obviously the covet is up
there and it's also very useful to have
them be othered
wonderful to have them be othered
because of the class implication of it
right you are being served there at the
table and masked down they are serving
masked up it's lovely the way it it
separates us
um
everything for division
right everything to divide us but then
the
the most amazing part of it to me is
at the point that you begin to realize
that this mask thing that the evidence
that the mask thing actually works by
putting you know putting them on healthy
people that that protects anybody it
does not right what's more mask versus
not mask is not the category most masks
are garbage right this is something i
got wrong okay most masks are garbage
for mass to stand any chance of doing
any good you have to get a really good
one and you have to know how to use it
and that's not what we're being mandated
to do right this is a symbolic gesture
that has got us constantly in the
mindset of covid and it is exactly the
same god damn thing as at the beginning
of this when they shut down the beaches
and the trails and you and i were saying
hey wait a minute outside is where you
want people to go they are safest out
there it's mentally good for them they
can interact with each other normally
and not be in such terrifying fear all
the time no they should sit inside eat
doritos play on social media and wait
for the vaccine that's effectively what
was being said and so the thing is the
masks um
are the way of getting the constant
reminder out there where it doesn't
belong
right and
it is amazing and the point is as soon
as you realize this and you say you know
what
the masks
really are that's the way the enemy has
intruded into every interaction that we
are going to have and we are obligated
to stand up against it but now you're in
a bind
right
if you don't wear your mask while others
are wearing the mask
you are one of two things
you are either enlightened about the
fact that the masks don't work and in
rebellion but much more likely you're
just not somebody who cares very much
about other people right you're not even
willing to put on a mask to protect
other people from a disease right and so
the point is that's that's the trap here
is that we can't rebel even those of us
who are enlightened and understand the
problem and frankly even me who was
ahead of this more than almost anybody
and championing masks as a an obvious
remedy at the beginning before we knew
that they didn't work
right even i am in this bind where i
can't stand up and say you know what i'm
not wearing the mask anymore and it's
not about the rest of you it's about the
people who are using this mask mandate
to
to separate the rest of us right i can't
make that point because just simply not
wearing a mask broadcast the message
that i'm inconsiderate of others health
which is not what motivates me at all
and yet part of what is being
demonstrated is that even
even we will comply with some things
right
so increasingly i think what we need
is a mechanism
whereby
if we have to put on a mask we can
indicate that we are not putting it on
out of belief that we are not going to
stigmatize anyone who decides that they
should not wear a mask because we know
the truth of the thing so that we are
not in the position of being induced to
broadcast a false message of
indifference to our fellow man in order
to rebel against some governmental
authority that is abusing its power
um and i don't know exactly how we get
there but we need to
we need to do it and we need to do it
right away because
because this mask thing is such genius
right they're getting us it's like
they've gotten all of us to wear their
logo broadcasting their brand everywhere
right and to put our own spin on it and
it's enough right this is this is evil
yeah
i agree
uh
maybe it's time
to talk about what you termed ethical
offense i think you just were i think we
were just we're talking about ethical
offense so maybe we've done that well i
want to add one thing too um
we because of the strange life that we
have been thrown into after uh leaving
our positions as college professors
we are reasonably we are pretty well
insulated compared to most people to
various kinds of mandates right because
you know
we run our own business out of our own
home we don't interact with as many
systems that are capable of inflicting
penalties on us but we've in fact run
into penalties twice this week and i'm
not going to talk about the particular
details of the organizations in question
[Music]
but twice we have encountered
discrimination
based on
a an unwillingness to
receive these vaccines
and no alternative is offered right it
is not that they are saying
you can't participate unless you provide
evidence that you don't have coveted
with a recent test which frankly i think
is probably unnecessary given where we
are with covid but i'd be willing to do
that right you know because we are not
indifferent to other people's health and
because covet is a serious disease
i wish i thought it was a a
truthful and accurate indicator
um but given that i don't believe that
of the vaccines anyway if you know if
we're in that landscape at least at
least having that be an option right
would be
would be a way to allow all human beings
to participate in whatever it is that
we're trying to participate in not even
just allow my suspicion based on
everything you and i have uncovered and
looked into is that a person who has a
negative test especially in fact in
light of the fact that the tests seem to
be biased in the direction of uh
diagnosing covid where it might not be
they tend more towards false positives
right
that's what you're saying yes
my suspicion is that a person who has a
recent negative test
is safer to be around from the point of
view of the likelihood of catching covet
from them than somebody who's been
vaccinated a month or two ago
who could very well have coveted and you
wouldn't know
so the point is if you're really trying
to protect your event
from kovid and i understand certainly
even if you didn't believe in these
vaccines as being safe and effective
i can certainly imagine being in the
position of hosting an event and
imagining that somebody's going to come
through the door and you know there
might be an event where people get
coveted at your you know at the thing
that you're hosting and you know
obviously there are consequences there
could be legal consequences why weren't
you vigilant about blah blah blah you
know and there could be uh
you know
damage to your organization's reputation
so i'm sympathetic and that's why i'm
willing at my own expense to get tested
to participate but what i'm not willing
to do
is pretend that it is acceptable for us
to be othering each other over
these remedies
these remedies are not high quality and
they're dangerous and there is no nuance
whatsoever being offered with them so
the idea you know that an organization
would say well you're not vaccinated you
can't participate when they didn't even
ask us if we'd had covid
right so if we had had covid and hadn't
had a vaccine we would be the safest
people to be around at least as far as
delta goes
so the fact they didn't ask means that
this isn't really about health in the
first place or it's so unnuanced us to
be absurd and so
enough we cannot continue othering each
other and that means
effectively note that you are being used
by something that hasn't even figured
out if it is interested in health at all
it hasn't even figured out how to age
stratify or how to separate out those
who are immune from a natural source
versus a vaccine source it hasn't done
any of this work right and it has you
othering other people that's an immoral
entity and so the point is we have to
start turning the heat up on those who
would do the bidding of of this thing
yes
yes and i actually saw um
we also saw
an example online this this wasn't this
didn't directly affect us
but there are some cities uh now that
actually have vaccine mandates for
indoor dining seattle is one of them
we were looking uh to eat
at a place not in seattle
where there are not mandates handed down
from the authorities but where some
cities or some institutions like
restaurants do have um vaccine mandates
most of them also say negative tests
within some number of hours at the door
but most most do not
and i was looking at a restaurant that
looked really fabulous and they had all
these great reviews except um
except somehow the overall review
average was very low and it was about
the three most recent reviews
who were all from it turns out members
of the same party had gone into the to
the same to the same meal and at first i
thought oh you know restaurant was
having an off night or something well it
turns out upon reading these reviews
that the major objection that the people
in this party had was that they went out
for some you know big event there were
many of them that went out to this meal
and that this restaurant did not require
proof of vaccination
and that on that basis these three
individuals who had what sounds like a
very good meal um were effectively
trying to engaging in the very same
tactics as cancel culture they they had
the ability given that this is uh a
restaurant that has not been in
existence for a lot of time and so
didn't have
so many reviews that the three most
recent ones being terrible didn't affect
the overall rankings um they had a
chance and especially in an era of you
know restaurants struggling to survive
and not being clear you know how what
they're going to be required to do by
the city or the state or whatever
um it was particularly appalling
that people would go after a restaurant
this way for
failing to
put up a
a
should be their choice vaccine mandate
for entry into their restaurant when
again
cobit is not the only risk to you out
there guys and for almost everyone it is
not the major risk to you by a long shot
and in and again i'm not going to use
the specifics here but the restaurant
owner or um or his agent
responded to the lengthiest of these
galling reviews and said we're very
sorry about these other experiences that
you had but with regard to vaccine
mandates
this is our choice we choose not to
require evidence of vaccination against
covet at the door
i was about to say he did not say like
nor do we require evidence of
vaccination against rabies at the door
right um and you know most people are
never going to run into rabies you and i
are vaccinated against rabies because we
once lived a life in which we were being
exposed potentially to rabies with some
regularity and and that vaccine was time
tested and understood to be effective as
well
so the owner stood up for himself and as
far as i can tell from the website
they're doing a brisk business still and
actually
actually doing it despite
despite the techniques
of frankly the the woke ideologues the
the
religious like people who would have us
believe
that all white people are racists and um
you can be a man if you say you're a man
or a woman if you say you're a woman and
um that all sexual assault is equivalent
and all of the other garbage that's
coming out of sort of social justice
ideology
those tactics cancel culture tactics are
now here over in um we found the next
enemy and uh it's it's you it's you're
dirty you're mean you're disrespectful
your heinous your evil if you're
unvaccinated you me you
if if if you are unvaccinated you're the
enemy and therefore
all rules are off the table i can do
whatever i want in order to get you
canceled and in this case a restaurant
that simply doesn't mandate that you as
an unvaccinated person are excluded yeah
it uh
effectively treats being unvaccinated
with these vaccines as synonymous with
being diseased and contagious yes and
that is preposterous if these vaccines
worked that would be preposterous but
these vaccines do not and gibraltar for
example tells you that their fantasy
world in which everybody gets vaccinated
and coveted goes away does not exist
right right so they don't have the right
to do this to us and so the question is
if i was running a business
frankly we see signs on doors that say
you know masks required and all i'm
increasingly annoyed by those signs i
don't know the extent to which those
signs are mandated versus voluntary in
in oregon it's mandated by our governor
right now the question then is can
somebody who is enlightened who
understands the reality of masks that
this is not an n95 mask mandate nor is
this a you know masked mandate that
correctly parses the difference between
putting a mask on a sick person and
putting a mask on a person who shows no
signs of being sick versus the absurdity
of putting a mask on somebody who's had
coveted and recovered and therefore is
really unlikely to transmit the disease
maybe at the level of zero likelihood
right
so what the question is maybe you know
if i ran a business and i had to put
that sign in my door
what else would i put on my door to
indicate that i was actually aware of
the absurdity of this and that the real
purpose was you know it's some variation
on uh the don't hurt me wall yes right
you know the the wall of signs that say
black lives matter was not about
somebody emphasizing by repeating it
that black lives matter was about
somebody broadcasting something about
their own you know compliance
and this is likewise not so dissimilar
from the videos that we saw of people
being harassed while dining right you
know put up your fist and say black
lives matter or we'll harass you on
video and broadcast it to the internet
right the question is oh you know can
you dine here well are you vaccinated
you know are you willing to say that
black lives matter on video it's all the
same thing what will they put up with
what everyone put up with how to what
degree well what percentage of the
population put up with this how about
this how about this now we know right
what then happens and it it is
effectively like
well we the agents of the narrative have
the right to demand that you indicate
that you are compliant with the
narrative and at the point you indicate
you aren't compliant with the narrative
then we have the right to stigmatize you
right and that is now happening it's not
exactly like it went down with woke and
blm but it's not so different either
it's clearly a variation on the same
playbook and you know this fits very
well with what we've been saying about
you know there's woke original flavor
woke and then there's medical woke
right and the point is these have
nothing to do with
science or a detailed analysis that
reveals a pattern that these are
narrative assertions that then cause
citizens
to step in and do what government cannot
right citizens are being used against
each other and it is very much you know
is it exactly brown shirts no but the
problem is
you know why are we in that quadrant of
the library why are we searching for
analogies in that quadrant of the
library that should be telling you
something
right that should be telling you
something and so the point is you know
what it's not brown shirts but
it's not so different either right it's
not tuskegee
but it's not so different either right
there are genuine real analogies to be
drawn here and the fact is that you know
exactly you put up the uh
image i sent ya
the water fountain
this is effectively what they're doing
to us right this iconic image of
separate drinking fountains
right we are being told that the world
has to break down this way and frankly i
don't know this is obviously way before
our time i don't know what the official
rational rationalization was for
separate drinking fountains i it
certainly has an epidemiological
implication right which is of course
obviously stupid and absurd it's not
like people within a race don't give
each other diseases right so this was
obviously a phony implication these
drinking fountains needed to be
separated and it's not so different well
yeah i mean i think the rhetoric like
now was around um dirtiness and lesser
status
and lesser worth yeah yeah it is and you
know enough so what i hope you know
there
obviously our core audience is not uh
new to the idea that something wrong is
afoot and that the narrative is taking
liberties it has no right to take and it
isn't based in science but for those who
are maybe encountering us early or
beginning to wake up to the idea that
they've been dragged into something that
isn't what they were told
please think about the degree to which
you are being used to do the bidding of
a government that can't do this itself
it needs your help to stigmatize other
citizens
and the first thing to do is to stop
complying
all right yeah
end of rant no that's
i think i think we need more of that
uh this week our friend mike nena which
is a name that will be familiar to many
of you uh he is a documentary filmmaker
uh he made among other things the um
he
he documented the grievance studies
affair with peter pagosian and helen
blecros and james lindsay and he also
produced
directed created all of it uh the
three-part
one-and-a-half hour total evergreen
documentary
which he sort of came to know uh as
as as we met him back when we did it
actually i guess we met him when we did
a
an event
we met him and peter burgosian and helen
blecros and james lindsey and james
damore all at the same event uh where uh
four of us were on stage and you
introduced us and
all this at portland state university
back in
spring of 2018 something like that so i
just want to add what i believe happened
was he was going to use evergreen as an
example in his documentary on uh
the um the so-called squared hoax the
studies the grievance studies affair
yeah
and
as we told him would happen if you dig
into the evergreen story a little bit
you're going to fall into this
incredible rabbit hole of absurdity and
that's in fact what happened and so he
did a separate little documentary on
evergreen
yeah it's not that little three parts
total if you haven't seen it it's
totally worth it you'll understand
things about about this and you know
it's also a good time capsule because it
was several years back
um but anyway he also uh participated
extensively with benjamin boyce in
putting that together a lot of the
footage there are things that benjamin
boyce collected cataloged um and uh you
know pried loose from
evergreen in benjamin the swear requests
that just wouldn't stop right and so
benjamin has done an incredible job
of
getting all of the material that
explains that event into the world so
anyway check out benjamin voice and mike
nina on youtube uh there's a whole world
of fascinating stuff yeah
so mike has become a friend we haven't
seen well anything of him in the last
two years of course but we haven't seen
much of him
um but he saw our clip
on what we understood to be happening in
australia
and he wrote he wrote to us at some
length and we had a little back and
forth and i'm going to post his entire
letter to us on my substance next
tuesday that's going to be my tuesday
post but um and you know
i asked him
you know what degree he wanted
to be anonymized and he said you don't
need to anonymize me at all i think this
is important to have in the world but
you know he says these are just some
things i've seen you know these are just
some things that i've jotted down about
what i've experienced being in australia
because australian
since since this all began
so he says
heather's analogy to the reporters
covering the portland riots in late 2020
is close to how i see it too
while gathering personal stories and
perspectives on the ground it becomes
clear that experiences differ from state
to state from suburb to suburb and even
house to house
there's something absurd in trying to
describe it at all in monolithic terms
australians are dot dot dot
some things that have stuck with me
though he says include
i saw a man in a canoe stopped by a
police boat
i was i was pulled over by two policemen
on motorbikes sirens and all for having
my nose sticking out at the top of my
mask it was a sunny day and i was alone
for at least 300 meters in all
directions
they were not polite
it was illegal for me to see my family
for the better part of a year even
outdoors
because they lived outside of a
permitted zone
my sister was home alone with two boys
aged four and six for around eight
months while her husband was stuck in
africa
we had to obtain a doctor's letter to
visit her
when i'd arrived she'd burst out of the
house as if she were escaping something
a friend went for a run was stopped by
police they checked her id and asked
what she was doing she said she was
exercising two hours later she got home
and they were waiting to find her for
exceeding the time limit for permitted
exercise
he's got a lot more again which i'll
post on natural selections on tuesday
yesterday mike sent another note as
follows
one more thing you might find
interesting and to keep you up to date
is that it's summer now and the east
coast of australia is at long last
moving from a zero covered paradigm into
a mitigation model my sense from talking
to family and looking at their instagram
feeds is that lives are looking a little
more normal and memories of the police
state are beginning to fade
i'm sure many like myself saw something
they don't want to forget so quickly and
are unsettled by the state's capacity to
flick the switch like they did
terrifying
so terrifying and as we said in the
original clip which he was
referring to um which he was responding
to
it does feel like there will be people
who will say i'm in australia and
that's not true and what they mean is
i'm in australia and i didn't see any of
those things
and that's
possible of course um presuma in some of
these cases only mike and say those
police officers are the ones who saw it
right
um but the idea that you will generalize
uh a a perfect you know pseudo-utopian
democratic state from not having
directly experienced things yourself
especially if you have uh the kinds of
privilege that many of the voices out of
australia who are claiming that nothing
is amiss there have
is
rather the opposite assumption that you
should have these examples
in this case from a trusted friend we
know he is not making any of these up
do provide evidence that something has
been very much a mess
they do not speak to
overall
pattern we don't know how many incidents
there were like any of those
but one person alone a person with a
trained eye who is who is experienced in
documenting things saw a number of
things across a number of domains that
were very much a mess did not remind him
of the country
uh that he calls home yeah we i think
the thing we really can't infer is how
patchy it is but he says that right
differs from suburb to suburb house to
house but the fact that one person
observed all of these things says
something really dramatic and i would
point out i've been thinking an awful
lot about julian assange
in light of his uh
losing his
motion to stave off extradition
and
it increasingly is clear to me that
you know i mean
i was
vocal
at the beginning of the assange affair
and
i don't think i was vocal enough because
i think the point is it was very hard to
make the case that this is the step onto
the slippery slope that leads somewhere
you will find impossible to believe
right we are now somewhere that many of
us find impossible to believe and the
point is
julian assange was the canary in the
coal mine and the absurd treatment that
he faced and the false portrayal that
has been so relentless um was a clear
indication that something wanted
rights to do this to a journalist that
embarrassed it right
this journalist did journalism
and
the the rights that no a person normally
has now he's not an american citizen so
in some technical sense he
lacks certain rights that he might
otherwise have but nonetheless something
clearly wanted to
uh
turn him into a political prisoner
torture him publicly so that we could
all watch him come apart so that others
wouldn't
wouldn't dare to do the same sort of
thing and we now have some indication of
why and no doubt the thing didn't know
about uh covet and in what context it
would abuse all of our rights but it did
know that it wanted the right to abuse
all of us and abusing all of us is a lot
easier with julian assange you know in a
cell somewhere and so anyway this is a
lesson of history that
i think we need to remind ourselves of
that you have to you have to prote
protest these things when they show up
at first because by the time it becomes
clear just how important and broad broad
the the threat is it it's too late you
know you're behind the eight ball at
that point
that's right
um
and it's even more important to protest
the things that are being done to
children
because what gets laid down in childhood
becomes very difficult if not impossible
to change
so we risk
destroying an entire generation
we do and uh
the reasons that you know the
the willingness the indifference to the
well-being of children that this
obviously illustrates
is spectacular and then there's a
question about why why they would do
this right
um and uh anyway it's something we
should revisit
all right well on that decidedly uh
downbeat note
i think we're there all right i think
we've arrived um
so we're going to take
a 15-minute break
and then be back with our live q a you
can ask your questions at
www.darkhorseadmissions.com
and
um we will have our monthly private q a
on my patreon tomorrow at 11am consider
joining us there
that will be our last regularly
scheduled uh live stream until the
saturday in the first second saturday in
2022 believe it or not um like i said at
the beginning of the hour we are likely
to do another live stream sometime
between christmas and new year's we're
not sure exactly when and we've got
brett's got three more already recorded
darkhorse podcasts uh in the can ready
to deploy uh sometime uh each of all of
those i think will be will be released
sometime between now and january 8th i
guess it will be
um
again consider reading a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century not yet available in lithuanian
or french or russian but it will be soon
and so you're restricted to english at
this point but it is available
uh we're proud of it and we've been
hearing from quite a lot of people
who've taken a lot of good from it we're
continuing to do
occasional podcasts um on
other people's podcasts about the book
and it's it continues to be
a source of joy actually so
anything else to say before we sign off
um consider
innovating something and putting
stand up with stand and up capitalized
innovating something some sort of
resistance that will let people know
just how many of us there are who are
not putting up with it any longer
indeed
and do what you can for yourself
including be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
you